to our other top story north Las Vegas
Police pacing together a crash that took
the lives of two young children late
last night good afternoon thank you for
joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce I'm
David charmsin for a Christian this
afternoon right now other passengers
remain in serious condition this all
happened in a neighborhood near Lone
Mountain and Clayton Ryan Matthey joins
us live from there now after speaking
with police just about a half hour ago
Ryan
Kirsten David just to give you all fair
warning the details of this story are
quite disturbing but police are
confirming to us right now the driver
allegedly speeding and Under the
Influence was a family member to the two
toddlers involved and you can see what's
left of the scene right here now both
were in adult seat belts police say
which left one of them decapitated
following the crash now what you're
seeing on your screen is North Las Vegas
Police footage of the scene just after 9
15 Sunday night the minivan hitting a
large tree head on after also side
swiping other trees a light post and a
wall police say four people were inside
the vehicle two of them were the
toddlers the other two are adults that
remain in the hospital in serious
condition one child was pronounced dead
on the scene the other at the hospital
neighbors who say they saw all this
jumped their backyard walls to help
those they could alleging the driver was
visibly intoxicated
when the firefighters came they when I
was taking her out the car she stepped
on the baby's leg without even caring
and then like
she just got out the car her nose was
busted I think she was more worried
about herself than the baby was than the
baby the black kid too and the kid after
been no more than one or two years old
this is a really little kid this is a
small child like probably no bigger than
my arm
now these neighbors add that the tree
was what potentially saved them from the
car driving straight through the wall
into their backyard and bedrooms all of
them say they are severely traumatized
now we're still unclear about what the
specific connection is between the
passengers they also said that they do
not have any information about potential
charges that the driver could be facing
reporting live from Lone Canyon and
Clayton rymathy a news now